hello my name is Brett champion and I'm
the visualization manager at will from
research and my talk is what's new and
visualization and the Wolfram language
and will cover everything from labeling
to stacked plots and different layouts
and new specialized visualizations in
geography and other areas thank you
hello good afternoon and welcome my name
is Brett champion and I'm the manager of
the visualization team here at Wolfram
research today I'm going to be talking
about what is what's new and
visualization focusing on mostly things
that have happened since this time last
year
so that's eleven point one and eleven
point two and I'd like to start off by
introducing some other members of my
team so Minh Truong Nirmal an annual Tim
and Rob and men will be giving a talk on
the labeling system that we've been
working on for visualizations tomorrow
at 10:00 a.m. and normal we'll be
talking about general scientific
visualization and going into some more
depth on recent improvements we've made
there tomorrow afternoon at 4:00 and
immanuel it'll we'll be talking about
Geographic visualization on Friday at
4:00
sorry 4:30 that right okay
and then also our department has been
has a booth set up downstairs where
we're holding office hours sort of one
hour slots by topic numeric symbolics
visualization and we have people that
will be down there tomorrow it's 10:00
and at 4:00 I think I was reading the
office hours before so and then 11
o'clock on Friday so if you have you
know additional visualization questions
that you want to ask that's a time and a
location that's guaranteed that
somebody's going to be there and and so
moving on as a quick overview there's
sort of about five areas in general that
I'm going to be that I've broken what's
new into so the first is sort of general
and some changes to rasterize and a new
graphics 3d option then within core
visualization which for us is sort of
you know a lot of the visualization
functions that have been in the system
forever and that we use a lot to extend
the system and build on top of and so
we're going to look at scaling functions
and stacked plots and then some advances
in labeling and the addition of geo
bubble chart for geographic
visualization and then finally look at
some of the specialized visualizations
especially features space plots and
Anatomy plot 3d so the big change for
rasterize which I don't know how many
people have used rasterize or realize
exactly what it has been doing and that
this is actually a change so for many
years we've had this function rasterize
and it has returns graphics of raster
and I'll try not to trip over the power
cord here and even after we introduced
image as you know a first class object
in the system rasterize was still
generating
the old-style output by default and and
so now in eleven point two it is
generating an actual image and so here
we have rasterize of a 3d sphere and if
we look at the bottom here I'll scroll
it up a bit we see that the head of that
object is now image and the byte count
is about four hundred K you can still
get the old graphics form from rasterize
by using the two argument form and
asking for graphics this is what was the
default in which case you get a graphics
and in this case let me just see if I
can put a little bit of empty space
below there and it was three megabytes
and and so by changing what rasterize is
returning by default it becomes more
efficient your notebooks will get
smaller things that are consuming this
will possibly hopefully be faster take
up less space on their own and that sort
of thing
so the next thing I want to mention is
the addition of the view projection
option to graphics 3d and hopefully I'm
not stealing too much of u2's talk at
five o'clock with this and so by default
we use graphics 3d uses slight
perspective and how it renders and so
there are you know the edges of this box
that surround the surface and the sides
that are theoretically parallel aren't
actually parallel they you know you can
klein a little bit toward each other to
give it a little bit of perspective and
for the most part I think that looks
really nice but there are cases
sometimes where you might not want that
where you want true orthographic
projection and you know the parallel
lines will be parallel and so we've
added this option view projection to
graphics 3d and to sort of everything
that builds on top of graphics 3d so all
the plots take this image 3d that sort
of thing
and and so one case where this might be
especially useful is if you want to look
at an object sort of straight on from
the front or from above or from the side
you can sort of see the difference here
with them without that option so when
you're doing it you know from the front
with an orthographic projection you
don't see any of the back edges because
they line up perfectly with where the
front ones would be whereas without when
we have the perspective you can see them
sort of angle back and you see more of
the surface like say this part you know
this back oscillation shows I mean you
see it because it's angling and you know
perspective wise and then so there's a
small change but no some uses for it and
you could sort of do this and sort of
slightly cumbersome ways by picking a
viewpoint that was far enough away that
the perspective really didn't have any
effect but this is actually done in a
dedicated way so it's there for your use
so moving on so I'll first say that a
lot of the development that we do these
days on the visualization team is
incremental yeah so in this version we
introduced a feature and it effects some
set of the visualization functions and
then we just sort of start incorporating
more and more of the visualization
functions to have support for it and so
scaling functions is an example of this
where you know in version 11 we had
support for plot and list plots and sort
of related families there and in version
11.1 we added support for plot 3d
contour plot density plot and their list
variants and and and so I just have a
couple of quick examples here so here I
have a plot 3d
and on the x-axis I've applied a log
scale the y-axis I'm just leaving is is
it's just a normal Weis you know linear
little Y scale and then the z axis I'm
using a reverse scaling function so that
it goes from 0 up here and then it
increases as I move down and so it sort
of flips it upside down it reverses it
yeah it's not strictly a flip because
that would change other orientations and
similarly for contour plots you know in
this case I still have my log scale on
the x-axis and again I'm using a reverse
tax you know a reverse scale in the Y
direction that goes from 0 down to 3 and
you can do you know everything that's
you know anything it has the same full
support for scaling function so if you
want to provide your own scaling
function then you can you know if you
provide sort of the forward you know
function and the inverse function the
other one that we started adding to a
lot of the visualization functions in
particular the functions that are sort
of centered around list plot and list
line plots is to add a layout option to
it and so first yeah this is an example
that is sort of how Lisp lot has behaved
for well let's say decades so I have two
data sets and when I plot them
there's drawn independently on the same
scale which is good and useful in lots
of cases and it makes it easy to see
okay the blue curve is on top here or
the red curves on top here and that sort
of thing but in version 11 point two we
added this plot layout option to this
line plot which we say plot layout goes
to stacked and now
what we're doing is we're drawing the
first curve which happens to be the red
one and then we're using that as the
baseline to draw the second curve on top
of and and so this is essentially the
same as plotting data 1 and theta 1 plus
theta 2 and so it may be that you know
well okay I could do this before why
would I want an option to do this for me
and it turns out there's some
interesting cases that can arise that
this helps you know deal with where this
straight up arithmetic isn't quite as
straightforward and I'll talk about that
in a moment
so we liked this so much that we
actually added not one but two new
functions that do this automatically so
the first is stacked to list plot and
the second we'll see in a minute
and part of the reason for stacked list
plot is that we also wanted to be able
to have the filling turned on by
defaults in these cases to sort of
extension you know to highlight that
this isn't just a normal list plot that
there's something sort of tying this
together give it a little bit more
volume to help draw attention to the
stacking that's going on and of course
this still supports scaling functions
and all the other options that let's
plot would support so there's also a
second setting well strictly speaking a
third setting for plot layout the second
one would be the default setting of none
which is percentile in which case we do
the stacking and then also normalize it
so that from bottom to top is sort of
represented by 100 units 100% and so now
we'll sort of look at why we aren't just
relying on data 1 plus data 2 and the
reason is things like what happens when
I have data sets that are irregularly
sampled and the sample points don't line
up so you can't just do a straight
of the data and so what you have is we
have you know three data sets which all
have XY pairs and so we draw our first
curve and I've turned the points on so
you can see where the actual sample
points for that curve are and then we
draw the second curve on top of it and
what you'll notice is that the sample
point for the second curve there's one
here and there's one here but you know
even though that those are the sample
points that curve you know sort of gets
a phantom point in the middle where this
first one had a point at this x-value so
that you know everything is accumulating
you know if you thought of this is an
increase of you know going from 6 to
going to 11 you know what would be a
straight line is picking up you know
sort of this bump as well and so and so
it's sort of a continuous you know it's
sort of a continuous operation and we're
looking at you know sort of how the
interpolation is going on and that sort
of thing and then like I said we added
you know not one but two functions and
the second is a date version so if you
have time series or other data with
dates you can easily incorporate that
into a stacked layout and so you can use
that easily as well so now we're going
to look at labeling which we've been
sort of rolling out slowly initially I
mean I think the first labeling we had
was in version seven when we introduced
the bar charts and pie charts and stuff
and they had sort of their own labeling
and then for a while we had this plot
that could do some labeling but we
didn't document it because it was still
sort of really experimental and not to
the state that we wanted yet
but ever since about version 11 or maybe
10-point something you know it's it's
gotten strong enough to where we can you
know really start to expose it and push
it out more and so in version 11 we
added call-outs for curves and and that
put sort of plot and list plot ahead of
the bar charts and pie charts for a
little bit because the plot supported
call out where the charts didn't and so
in version 11.1
- - at least the 2d charting functions
3d we're still experimenting with and
ironing out exactly how labeling works
in that environment so here we have bar
chart with call-outs on each of the bars
instead of just labeling and so
everything is lines up and if I had lots
of labels it would sort of go to
multiple rows of labels so that things
weren't running into each other
similarly for stacked bar charts pie
charts we had a version of this
originally with the radio call-out
placement for labels this one is a
little bit better it's a little bit more
aggressive in positioning the labels so
that they won't overlap especially in
cases where you have sort of these small
slices that are close to each other and
bubble chart is where things you know
we've really sort of gone more
aggressive so the call-outs in bubble
charts you know for small bubbles or
relatively large labels you get you know
something that actually looks like a
call-out but you'll notice that many of
these the default location that we've
chosen for the call-out is just to stick
it right there in the middle of the
bubble in the cases where it fits and
you know there's cases up here where you
know say this larger bubble would be
able to contain its label except that
there's another bubble that's intruding
on it and and so in that case there
resort back to you know call outs with
the leader line connecting back to the
bubble so the other thing we did in
eleven point two with labeling is really
push the performance on it so we'd
gotten to a point where it worked
reasonably well and we were happy were
mostly happy with how the actual
positioning of the labels was done and
then we came back and said okay if I
have lots of points this is too slow how
can we speed this up and so my sample
code here is you know fixed random seed
I generate a certain you know a certain
number of labeled points and I feed it
to list plots and see how long it takes
and and so for labeling 50 points took
about you know three quarters of a
second on my machine a thousand points
took three minutes and it I mean so
let's plot when it's labeling points
will start throwing away labels if
they're going to start colliding too
much and so you get a thousand points
you spend three minutes and there's
maybe 20 30 points that actually got
labeled so so now let's look at you know
what we got to in version 11 point 2 so
the 50 points got down to you know under
you know quite a bit faster about a
factor of 5,000 points got down to a
second so now you can include a lot more
labels without sort of worrying nearly
so much about is this gonna kill the
performance of you know the plot that
I'm trying to generate and additionally
at the same time we've sort of improved
some of the layout algorithms so that in
many cases it'll 11.2 is able to fit in
even more points so here's the same set
of points and there's 250 of them that
we've asked to be labeled I haven't
counted to see how many are actually
labeled in each one
but clearly 11.2 is fit more labels into
the plot and additionally if you find a
point that doesn't have a label and it's
going to not show up really well but
when I mouse over there is a tooltip
right there that tells me what that
label would have been you know but it's
you know you can't see it immediately
because it would be colliding with
everything else and so now we'll look at
[Music]
see if I managed to get stuff out of
order one of the specialty visualization
functions which is feature space plot I
didn't accidentally skip yeah that's
just out of order okay
and so feature space plot is a
visualization function that sort of came
out of a lot of the machine learning
work and conceptually it's very simple
at least from my viewpoint which is it
takes your data and runs it through
dimension reduce and so in this case
it's taking a whole bunch of images
about 240 of them one for every country
and it's reducing each of these flags to
a pair of numbers I don't know the
details of how it does this is magic
black magic but it does some interesting
things so once we get down to a pair of
numbers we're then sort of drawing
because these are images we can use them
to self label themselves and so we just
draw the flag everywhere that you know
at each of the points that it came up
with and sort of some of the things that
are sort of interesting is that you get
sort of across the middle lots of
horizontal stripes down here on the
right hand side you get all the British
Commonwealth nations that you know New
Zealand and Australia and I don't even
know what all of them are that have very
similar appearances down here they're
further in the bottom you get a lot of
the flags that contain crosses over here
you have sort of horizontal stripes with
some
in the middle some sort of circular
element and then up here we have the
ones that have sort of a triangle along
the left edge that pokes into the center
of the flag and so that's sort of
interesting and it's being sort of
computed automatically by dimension
reduce using whatever feature extractors
it uses by default if you change the
feature extractor so in this case I'm
using I'm saying that I want the pixels
to be turned into vectors then we get
something that's much more classified
based on what colors are predominant in
each of the flags with blue at the top
coming down to green and then you know
sort of red at the bottom and and so
that's sort of interesting and you don't
just have to use images I mean it just
makes the best demonstrations it can be
sort of arbitrary data and then there's
extractors the deal with audio and
vectors and matrices and text and all
sorts of things and and so now we'll you
know come to geo bubble chart which is
the latest member in the
geovisualization family inversion 11.1
this is fairly straightforward its
geographic data and bubble chart and you
sort of merge them in the obvious way
and so here we have an example with the
largest cities in the United Kingdom and
you know London is by far the largest of
the cities but so the thing is that
because we're leveraging sort of bubble
chart you know it gets all the same
benefits that bubble chart has and so in
particular some of the labeling that I
showed earlier so here we have Miami New
York Seattle and Los Angeles and I've
given each of them a an arbitrary value
and I've said that I want them to be
labeled with call-outs of Miami you know
in Seattle and New York and LA are
abbreviated
and so because event just sort of
natively using everything that it gets
from bubble charts New York and LA have
their labels inside the bubbles and
Seattle and Miami get the call-out and
so if you've used bubble chart
moving on to geo bubble chart for your
geographic data is completely
straightforward and so the final slide
is about an anime plot 3d so we added
this and I think version 11 using a lot
of data that we have on the knowledge
base and it was one of the functions
that at the time we added it we weren't
quite sure what we wanted to do with it
theme wise and so it didn't originally
support the plot team option and so for
11.2 we came back and added that
framework to it and we're able to do
some interesting things with it I think
so the first is that so we have this
detailed theme which gives us axes and
then also gives us tooltips on each of
the different components in the plot
scientific uses unique colors for
everything to help distinguish where one
part ends and another part ends and
again has the tooltips on it which don't
show up terribly well but they're there
and then there's a couple of themes that
are specific to anatomy plot 3d one is
vintage which is sort of historical
rendering ish effect and I think
possibly the colors don't reproduce on
this monitor or this projector very well
the background is much more of a sepia
type color you know a tannish rather
than a blueish gray and then the final
one is sort of a simulated x-ray not
completely truthful or faithful to an
actual x-ray but enough to give you an
idea
I think our x-ray theme still
accentuates some types of tissue that
would be almost completely invisible to
an actual x-ray so that you can still
get some hint of what is there so thank
you and that finishes my talk
[Applause]
you